movie about men running through tight
spaces my kind of movie that's a [ __ ]
joke The Maze Runner I'm pretty lean on
catching this movie so you probably
don't give a [ __ ] anymore to hear about
it but I'm gonna talk about it anyway
first off I did not read the book I want
to make that clear I did not read the
book I'm gonna judge this film based off
its own merits
[ __ ] back off this movie is very
entertaining it's not like filled with
humor or something
it's actually a rather serious dark
picture but it is quite the thrill ride
like when ladies ride the Ryan aider
Trico my penis I call it a bunch of
things if you don't know what this in
office is I don't want to go over it
it's in the explanation box go read it I
felt like what really made this movie
work was the direction of it it doesn't
have like a young adult novel volume
about it it had its own vibe and it
embraced that and it also had
interesting aspects of survival and who
one must become to achieve that overcome
such obstacles films really about
success what it takes to be successful
endurance belief in yourself courage and
a big dick this is a really dick themed
review the film was dark at times it was
menacing at times it was actually really
scary that was my girlfriend and she was
like flippin balls the whole time
literally doesn't even make sense yeah
the film does take its time but when the
action sequences are there there are
plenty of them it's [ __ ] entertaining
man let's put it like this if you don't
feel like running once this movie is
done you're probably too fat the may
sequences and designs were all great it
looked real it was a combination of
practical and special effects and it has
just wonderfully directed action scenes
cuz they're actually invested in the
characters so you actually give a [ __ ]
about what's going on it gets your heart
beating your adrenaline pumping your
penis pulsing dick jokes ha the director
just really seemed to understand its
actors and its characters I mean there's
a lot of characters but each gets just
the right amount of treatment for the
silver screen they each get their own
time to shine dylan o'brien as thomas
this is not logan lerman I repeat this
is not logan lerman
you will look like an idiot if you go up
to your friends and you say Logan alert
was the start of it then they're gonna
be like no you're dumbass and then
you're gonna be like [ __ ] you you're not
my friends anymore you guys he's the
main character a rebel with the legit
cause which is to get the [ __ ] out of
there the dude carries this movie he's a
great [ __ ] actor his sense of fear
his sense of courage his curiosity his
ambition his worries all that just
resonates throughout his performance
Thomas brodie-sangster hope I said your
name right you [ __ ] get a better
name that everyone can pronounce how do
you expect to get famous with a name
like that he plays mute he becomes one
of Thomas's closest allies and he's a
great supporting performance it's a very
sincere performance like it makes me
think I might like this kid in real life
will Poulter as uh as a [ __ ] don't
remember the character's name all I
remember is the VIS dudes a [ __ ] I mean
don't get me wrong this dude will he
does a great job in the role it's
definitely one of the more emotional
roles in the film he's not exactly the
antagonist but he's not supportive of
the protagonist like every other one of
his lines is so uh why don't we uh what
are we gonna punish this guy this guy's
Asian this guy's black and this is a
woman yes this film has diversity but on
a serious note there is diversity in the
film and I like how they don't make that
like really in your face they just write
them as humans as all races should be
except for the two they chose in this
movie but other than that so yeah this
movie definitely delivers my complaints
are minimal compared to what's actually
good about this film I thought the first
half of this movie had a pretty good
amount of cliche lines for a film like
this I found myself way too often
predicting the next line that was coming
as far as the ending of this movie goes
I'm not gonna give it away but I will
say this the whole time you're watching
it you're like I really want to know
what's going on and then by the time it
ends you're saying I really want to know
I mean don't get me wrong you do get
some answers but I feel like they didn't
answer some questions and then they open
the door to a billion other questions
it's kind of like lost we got to get to
handle often
Island like I said I didn't read the
book but as far as the movie goes I
found it to be overall pretty great
it's just when the ending I didn't feel
fully satisfied I am quoting most women
I just wanted a more solidified
conclusion that's all but I'm sure a lot
of you won't mind it let me get straight
to the point here all in all I gotta say
the Maze Runner got it super duper
running through life right alright guys
thanks for checking out my review for
the Maze Runner why don't you go ahead
scroll that comment box below and you
tell me would you rather sleep with
Dylan O'Brien or Logan Lerman I'm
walking out there you can follow us on
our social networks do it because I'm a
youtuber and I gotta say [ __ ] like that
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews or
videos is out going to click on this
button about my dick to subscribe that's
right good dick let me tell you
something about this little runner he
has found his way through the maze of
many women's vaginas because he
occasionally gets it in the wrong hole